especially the Auntie woke I don't even  think it has anything to do with his  so-called misogynistic views I don't  really think they're misogynistic but I  don't think it has anything to do with  that I think it has everything to do  with the fact that he's pulling people  out of the Matrix so he's waking people  up he's saying nobody's coming to save  you forget that nine to five you need to  save yourself you don't need  antidepressants let me teach you how to  fight depression by yourself literally  empowering men to save themselves and I  think that men are the Forefront of  society like if you have weak men  Society crumbles if you have strong  women it doesn't really matter it's the  men that matter so if you have strong  men then Society can flourish in every  different way like the powers that be  don't want us flourishing because less  control